you you did uh a great video on molok
and one aspect of it the application of
it to yeah
instagram beauty filters
very niche uh i wanted to start off
small um
so uh
molok was originally
um
[Music]
coined
as well so apparently back in the like
uh
canaanite times it was to say ancient
carcinogenian i can never say it
carthage in
somewhere around like 300 bc or
280 i don't know um there was supposedly
this death cult
who
would sacrifice their children to this
awful demon god thing they called molok
um in order to get power to win wars so
really dark horrible things and it was
literally like about child sacrifice
whether they actually existed or not we
don't know but in mythology they they
did and this god that they worshipped
was this thing called molok
and then
i don't know it seemed like it was kind
of quiet throughout history um in terms
of mythology beyond that until um this
movie metropolis uh in 1927
talked about um
this
you see that there was this incredible
futuristic city that everyone was living
great in um but then the protagonist
goes underground into the sewers and
sees that the city is run by this
machine
and this machine basically would just
like kill the workers all the time
because it was just so hard to keep it
running they were always dying so
there's all this suffering that was
required in order to keep the city going
and then the protagonist has this vision
that this machine is actually this demon
moloch so again it's like this sort of
like mechanistic consumption of of
humans in order to get more power um and
then alan ginsberg wrote a poem in the
60s um which incredible poem called howl
about this thing molok um
and a lot of people sort of quite
understandably take the the
interpretation of that he's that he's
talking about capitalism um
but then the bet like the sort of piece
the resistance that's moved molok into
this idea of game theory uh was scott
alexander of slate star codex um
wrote this incredible one literally i
think it might be my favorite piece of
writing of all time it's called
meditations on molok everyone must go
read it uh
and i say codex is a blog it's a blog
yes
we can link to it in the show notes or
something right um no don't
i
yes yes but i i like how you do how how
you assume i have a professional
operation going on here i i shall try to
remember
you're giving the impression of it yeah
yeah i'll like please if i if i don't
please somebody in the comments remind
me i'll also
you don't know this blog it's one of the
best blogs ever probably you should
probably be following it yes
our blog's still a thing i think that
there's still a thing yeah he's migrated
onto substance but yeah it's still a
blog um
better not [ __ ] things up but i have not
yeah i hope they don't i hope they don't
turn moloki which will mean something to
people when we continue
when they stop interrupting for once
that's good
yeah so anyway so he writes he writes
this this piece meditations on molok and
basically
he analyzes the poem and he's like okay
so it seems to be something relating to
where competition goes wrong
and
you know moloch was historically this
thing of like where people would
sacrifice
a thing that they care about in this
case children their own children
in order to gain power a a competitive
advantage
and if you look at
almost everything that sort of goes
wrong in our society it's that same
process
um so with the instagram beauty filters
thing um
you know if you're trying to become a a
famous
instagram model
you are incentivized to post the hottest
pictures of yourself that you can you
know you're trying to play that game um
there's a lot of hot women on instagram
how do you compete against them you post
really hot pictures and that's how you
get more likes
as technology gets better um you know
more
makeup techniques come along um and then
more recently these beauty filters where
like at the touch of a button it makes
your face look absolutely incredible um
compared to your natural natural natural
face uh these these technologies come
along it's everyone is incentivized to
that short-term strategy um
but
over on on net it's bad for everyone
because now everyone is kind of like
feeling like they have to use these
things and these things like they make
you like the reason why i talked about
them in this video is because i noticed
it myself you know like i i was trying
to grow my instagram for a while i've
given up on it now but um yeah and i
noticed these filters how good they made
me look and i'm like well
i know that everyone else is kind of
different you subscribed who lives
instagram please
uh post a bunch of yeah
make make it blow up uh so yeah it's you
felt the pressure actually exactly
these short-term incentives to do this
like this thing that like either
sacrifices your integrity
or something else um in order to like
stay competitive um which on aggregate
turns like
creates this like sort of race to the
bottom spiral where everyone else ends
up in a situation which is worse off
than if they hadn't start you know than
it were before kind of like if um
like a
at a football stadium
uh like the system is so badly designed
a competitive system of like everyone's
sitting and having a view that if
someone at the very front stands up to
get an even better view it forces
everyone else behind to like adopt that
same strategy just to get to where they
were before but now everyone's stuck
standing up like so you need this like
top-down god's eye coordination to make
it go back to the better state but from
within the system you can't actually do
that so that's kind of what this molok
thing is it's this thing that makes
people sacrifice uh
values in order to optimize for the the
winning the game in question the
short-term game but this this molec
do you can you attribute it to any one
centralized source or is it an emergent
phenomena from a large collection of
people
exactly that it's it's an emergent
phenomena it's it's a force of game
theory
um it's a force of bad incentives on a
multi-agent system where you've got more
you know prisoner's dilemma is
technically a kind of molecule
you know system as well but it's just a
two-player thing but um another word for
molecular multi-polar trap
where basically you just got a lot of
different people all competing for some
kind of prize
and
it would be better if everyone didn't do
this one shitty strategy but because
that strategy gives you a short-term
advantage everyone's incentivized to do
it and so everyone ends up doing it so
the responsibility for
i mean social media is a really nice
place for a large number of people to
play game theory and so
they also have the ability to then
design the the rules of the game
and uh is it on them to try to
anticipate what kind of
like to do the thing that poker players
are doing to run simulation
ideally that would have been great if
you know mark zuckerberg
and jack and all that you know the
twitter founders and everyone if they
had at least just
run a few simulations of how
their algorithms would you know
different types of algorithms would turn
out for society that would have been
great that's really difficult to do that
kind of deep philosophical thinking
about thinking about humanity actually
so not
not kind of this level of how do we
optimize engagement
or what brings people joy in the short
term but how is this thing going to
change the way people see the world how
is it going to get morphed in iterative
games played
into something that
will change society forever that's that
requires some deep thinking that's
i hope there's meetings like that inside
companies but there aren't that's the
problem and and
it's it's difficult because like when
you're starting up a social media
company you know you're aware that you
you've got investors to please
there's
you bills to pay um you know there's
only so much r d you can afford to do
you've got all these like incredible
pressures that you know bad incentives
to get on and just build your thing as
quickly as possible and start making
money
and you know i don't think anyone
intended when they built these social
social media platforms and just to like
preface it so the reason why you know
social media is relevant because it's a
very good example of like everyone these
days is optimizing for
you know clicks
um whether it's the social media
platforms themselves because you know
every click gets more you know
impressions and impressions pay for you
know
they get advertising dollars or whether
it's individual influencers or you know
whether it's the new york times or
whoever they're trying to get their
story to go viral so everyone's got this
bad incentive of using you know as you
call it the click bait industrial
complex um that's a very moloky system
because everyone is now using worse and
worse tactics in order to like try and
win this attention game um
and
yeah so
ideally these companies would have had
enough slack in the beginning
in order to run these experiments to see
okay what are the ways this could
possibly go wrong for people what are
the ways that molok they should be aware
of this concept of molok and realize
that it's any whenever you have a highly
competitive multi-agent system which
social media is a classic example of
millions of agents all trying to compete
for likes and so on and you try and
bring all this complexity down into like
very small metrics such as number of
likes number of retweets whatever the
algorithm optimizes for that is a like
guaranteed recipe for this stuff to go
wrong and become a race to the bottom
yeah i think there should be an honesty
when founders i think there's a hunger
for that kind of transparency of like we
don't know what the [ __ ] we're doing
this is a fascinating experiment we're
all running
as a human civilization let's try this
out yes and like actually just be honest
about this that we're all like
these weird rats and a maze
not none of us are controlling it
there's this kind of sense like the
founders
the ceo of instagram or whatever mark
zuckerberg has a control and he's like
like with strings playing people no
they're he's at the mercy of this is
like everyone else he's just like trying
to do his best
and like i think putting on a smile and
doing over uh polished videos about
how instagram and facebook are good for
you
i think is not the right way to uh to
actually ask some of the deepest
questions we get to ask as a society how
do we design the game
such that we build a better world i
think a big part of this as well is
people
there's this
there's this philosophy particularly in
silicon valley um
of well techno optimism technology will
solve all our issues
and there's a steel man argument to that
where yes technology has solved a lot of
problems and can potentially solve a lot
future ones
but it can also it's always a
double-edged sword and particularly as
you know technology gets more and more
powerful and we've now got like big data
and we're able to do all kinds of like
psychological manipulation with it and
so on um
it's
technology is not about values neutral
thing people think i used to always
think this myself it's like this naive
view that oh technology is completely
neutral it's just it's the humans that
either make it good or bad no
to the point we're at now the technology
that we are creating they are social
technologies they literally
dictate
how humans now form social groups and so
on beyond that and beyond that it also
then that gives rise to like the memes
that we then like coalesce around
and that you know if you have the stack
that way where it's technology driving
social interaction which then drives
like mimetic uh mimetic culture and like
which ideas become popular that's molok
and the we need the other way around we
need it so we need to figure out what
are the good memes what are the good
um
values
that we think are
we we need to optimize for that like
makes people happy and healthy and like
keeps society as robust and safe as
possible then figure out what the social
structure around those should be and
only then do we figure out technology
but we're doing the other way around and
you know like as much as i love
in many ways the culture of silicon
valley and like you know i do think that
technology has you know i don't want to
knock it it's done so many wonderful
things for us same with capitalism um
there are
we have to like be honest with ourselves
we're getting to a point where we are
losing control
of this very powerful machine that we
have created can you redesign the
machine within the game
can can you just have
can you understand the game enough okay
this is the game and this is how we
start to reemphasize the memes that
matter
the the memes that bring out the best in
us
uh you know like the way
i try to be in real life and the way i
try to be online is to be about kindness
and love and i feel like i'm
sometimes
get like criticized for being naive and
all those kinds of things but i feel
like i'm just trying to live
within this game i'm trying to be
authentic
yeah but also like
hey it's kind of fun to do this like you
guys should try this too you know that
and that's like
trying to redesign
some aspects of the game within the game
um is that possible
i don't know
but i think we should try
uh i don't think we have an option but
to try well the other option is to
create new companies or to
pressure companies
uh that or anyone who has control of the
rules of the game i think we need to be
doing all of the above
i think we need to be thinking hard
about what are the kind of positive
healthy memes
um
uh
you know as as elon said he who controls
the memes controls the universe um i
think he did yeah
um but there's truth to that
it's very there is wisdom in that
because
memes have driven history you know we
are we are a cultural species that's
what sets us apart from chimpanzees and
everything else we have the ability to
learn and evolve through culture
as opposed to biology or like you know
classic physical constraints
and that means culture is incredibly
powerful
and we can create and become victim to
very bad memes or very good ones um but
we do have some agency over which means
you know we we sub but not only put out
there but we also like subscribe to
um so i think we need to take that
approach we also need to
you know because i don't want the the
the the you know i'm making this video
right now are called the attention wars
which is about like how molok like the
media machine is this molok machine uh
well is this is this kind of like blind
dumb thing that where everyone is
optimizing for engagement in order to
win their share of the attention pie um
and then if you zoom out it's really
like molok that's pulling the strings
because the only thing that benefits
from this in the end you know like our
our information ecosystem is breaking
down like we are
you look at the state of the us it's in
we're we're in a civil war it's just not
a physical war it's it's it's a
it's an information war and people
people are becoming more fractured in
terms of what their actual shared
reality is like truly like an extreme
left person an extreme right person like
they they
they literally live in different worlds
in their in their in their minds at this
point and it's getting more and more
amplified and this this force is like a
like razor blade pushing through
everything it doesn't matter how
innocuous the topic is it will find a
way to split into this you know
bifurcated culture war and it's [ __ ]
terrifying because that maximizes
attention and that's like an emergent
moloch type force right that takes any
anything any topic
and cuts through it so they it can split
nicely
into two groups one one that's what is
is whatever yeah
all everyone is trying to do within the
system is just maximize whatever gets
them the most attention because they're
just trying to make money so they can
keep their thing going right
and the way the the the best emotion for
getting attention in well because it's
not just about attention on the internet
it's engagement that's the key thing
right in order for something to go viral
you need people to actually engage with
it they need to like comment or retweet
or whatever
um
and of all the emotions the
uh you know there's like seven classic
shared emotions that studies have found
that all humans even from like un un
previously uncontacted tribes have um
some of those are negative you know like
sadness
uh disgust
anger etc summer positive happiness
um excitement and so on the one that
happens to be the most useful for the
internet is anger because anger is
it's
such an active emotion if you want
people to engage
if someone's scared and i'm not just
like talking about my [ __ ] there are
studies here they've looked into this um
where it's like if someone's like
disgusted or fearful they actually tend
to then be like uh i don't want to deal
with this so they're less likely to
actually engage and share it and so on
they're just gonna be like whereas if
they're enraged by a thing well now that
like that triggers all the like the the
old tribalism emotions um and so that's
how then things get sort of spread you
know much more easily they out-compete
all the other memes in the ecosystem um
and so this like
the the attention economy the the wheels
that make it go around are is rage
um i did a you know tweet the the the
the problem with raging against the
machine is that the machine has learned
to feed off rage because it is feeding
off our age that's the thing that's now
keeping it going so the more we get
angry the worse it gets
um so the molok and this attention
in in the war of attention is
constantly maximizing rage what it is
optimizing for is engagement and it
happens to be the engagement
um
is
well propaganda you know i mean it just
sounds like every everything is is
putting is more things being put through
this like propagandist lens of winning
whatever the war is in question whether
it's the culture war or the ukraine war
yeah well i think the silver lining of
this do you think it's possible that in
the long arc of this process you
actually do arrive
at greater wisdom and more progress it's
just in the moment it feels like people
are
tearing each other to shreds over ideas
but if you think about it one of the
magic things about democracy and so on
is you have the blue versus red
constantly fighting it's almost like
they're
in
discourse
creating devil's advocate making devils
out of each other and through that
process
discussing ideas
like almost really embodying different
ideas just to yell at each other and
through the yelling over the period of
decades maybe centuries figuring out a
better system like in the moment it
feels [ __ ] up right but in the long
arc it actually is pretty productive
i hope so um
that said
we are now in the era of
just as we have weapons of mass
destruction with nuclear weapons
you know that can break the whole
playing field
we now are developing weapons of
informational mass destruction
information white pens you know wmds
that
basically can be used for propaganda or
just
manipulating people however they you
know is needed whether that's through
dumb tick-tock videos or you know there
are significant
resources being put in um i don't mean
to sound like you know
to doom and gloom but there are
bad actors out there that's the thing
there are plenty of good actors within
the system who are just trying to stay
afloat in the game so we're effectively
doing monarchy things but then on top of
that we have actual bad actors who are
intentionally trying to like manipulate
the other side into doing things and
using uh so because of the digital space
they're able to use
uh
artificial actors meaning bots exactly
botnets you know and this is a whole new
situation that we've never had before
yeah it's exciting you know you know
what i want you to do you know what i
want to do that um because there is you
know people talking about boss
manipulating and
uh have like malicious bots that are
basically spreading propaganda i want to
create like a bot army
for like that like fights that yeah
exactly for love that fights though that
i mean you know there's there i mean
there's truth to fight fire with fire
it's like but how
you always have to be careful whenever
you create again like malloc is very
tricky yeah hitler was trying to spread
the love too well yeah so we thought but
you know i i i agree with you that like
that is a thing that should be
considered but there is
again everyone the road to hell is paved
in good intentions
and this is
there's a there's always unforeseen
circums you know outcomes uh
externalities of you trying to adopt a
thing even if you do it in the very best
of faith well you can learn lessons if
you can run some sims on it first
absolutely but but also there's certain
aspects of a system as we've learned
through history that
do better than others like for example
don't have a dictator so um like if i
were to create this bot army it's not
good for me to have full control over it
because in the beginning i might have a
good understanding of what's good and
not but over time that starts to get
deviated because i'll get annoyed at
some [ __ ] and i'll think okay
wouldn't it be nice to get rid of those
[ __ ] but then that power starts
getting to your head you become
corrupted that's basically human nature
so distribute the power so we need we
need a
a love
botnet
on a dao
a dao love botnet yeah but and without a
leader like without exactly a
distributed right yeah without any kind
of centralized yeah without even you
know basically is the more control the
more you can decentralize the control of
a thing
uh to people
you know but the the the but they don't
need the ability to coordinate because
that's the issue when you if something
is too you know that's really to me like
the culture wars is the bigger war we're
dealing with is actually between
the like the sort of i don't know what
even the term is for it but like
centralization versus decentralization
that's the tension we're seeing
power in control by a few versus
completely distributed and
the trouble is if you have a fully
centralized thing then you're at risk of
tyranny you know stalin type things can
happen uh or completely distributed uh
now you're at risk of complete anarchy
and chaos where you can't even
coordinate to like on you know when
there's like a pandemic or anything like
that so it's like what is the right
balance to strike between these two well
structures can't malloc really take hold
in a fully decentralized system that's
the one of the dangers too yes the the
very vulnerable so the dictator can
commit huge atrocities but they can also
make sure the the infrastructure works
and uh
the training they have that god's eye
view at least they have the ability to
create like laws and rules that like
force coordination
which stops molog but then you're
vulnerable to that dictator getting
infected with like this with some kind
of psychopathy type thing
what's uh what's reverse molok
sorry great question so
i that's
where
i've been working on this series it's
been driving me insane for the last year
and a half uh i did the first one a year
ago i can't believe it's nearly been a
year uh the second one hopefully will be
coming out in like a month um
and my goal at the end of the series is
to like present because basically i'm
painting the picture of like what molok
is and how it's affecting almost all
these issues in our in our society and
how it's you know driving it's like kind
of the generator function as people
describe it uh of existential risk
and then at the end of that wait wait
the generator function of existential
risk so you're saying molecules that are
the engine that creates
a bunch a bunch of x-risks yes not all
of them like like a uh you know a um
just a cool phrase generator function
it's not my phrase it's it's daniel
shmachtenberger oh i got that from him
of course all things it's like all the
roads lead back to daniel
schmuckenberger the dude is the dude is
brilliant no he's he's not afraid of
that it's mark twain
well anyway sorry
um totally rude interruptions from me no
it's fine uh so not all likes risks so
like an asteroid technically isn't
because it's um
you know it's just like this one big
external thing it's not like a
competition thing going on but you know
synthetic biola you know
bio weapons that's one because
everyone's incentivized to build
even for defense you know bad bad
viruses you know just threaten someone
else etc or ai technically the race to
adi is kind of potentially a monarchy
situation um
but
yeah so
if molok is this like generator function
that's driving all of these issues over
the coming century that might wipe us
out
what's the inverse and so far what i've
gotten to is this character that i want
to put out there called win-win
because monica's the god of lose-lose
ultimately it masquerades as the god of
win lose but in reality it's lose-lose
everyone ends up worse off
so i was like well what's the opposite
of that it's win-win and i was thinking
for ages like what's a good name for
this character
and then the more i was like okay well
don't try and you know think through it
logically what's the vibe of win-win and
to me like in my mind molok is like and
i dressed as it in the video like it's
red and black it's kind of like very
you know hyper focused on it's one goal
you must win um so win-win is kind of
actually like these colors it's like
purple turquoise um
it's
loves games too
it loves a little bit of healthy
competition but constrained so kind of
like before like knows how to ring fence
zero sum competition into like just the
right amount uh whereby its
externalities can be controlled and kept
positive
and then beyond that it also loves
cooperation coordination love all these
other things um but it's also kind of
like mischievous
uh
like you know it will have a good time
it's not like kind of like boring you
know like oh god it's it's it always had
to have fun it can get like it can get
down um but ultimately it's like
unbelievably wise and it just wants the
game to keep going
um and i call it win-win um that's a
good like pet name yes win-win the i
think the win
right and i think it's formal name when
it has to do like official functions is
uh omnia
omnia yeah
from like um omniscience kind of what's
why omnia you just like when omni win
but i'm open to suggestions oh like you
know and this is oh come here yeah yeah
like that but there's an angelic kind of
sense to omnia though so win-win is more
fun so it's more it's more like um
uh it embraces the
the the the fun aspect i mean there
there is something about sort of um
there's some aspect to win-win
interactions that requires
embracing
[Music]
the chaos of the game and enjoying the
game itself
i don't know i don't know what that is
that's almost like a zen-like
appreciation of of the game itself not
optimizing for the consequences of the
game
right well it's recognizing
the value of competition in of itself
about it's not like about winning it's
about you enjoying the process of having
a competition and not knowing whether
you're going to win or lose this little
thing but then also being aware
that you know what's the boundary how
big do i want competition to be because
one of the reasons why molok is doing so
well
now in our society in our civilization
is because we haven't been able to ring
fence competition
uh you know and so it's just having all
these negative externalities and it's
we've completely lost control of it um
you know it's
i think
my guesses are now we're getting really
like
you know metaphysical technically but i
i think
uh we'll be we'll be in a more
interesting universe if we have one that
has both
pure cooperation you know lots of
cooperation
and some pockets of competition then one
that's purely competition cooperation
entirely like it's good to have some
little zero sumness bits um but i don't
know that fully and i'm not qualified as
a philosopher to know that and that's
what reverse molex so this kind of
win-win creature is an
uh system as an antidote to the molex
system
yes
and
i don't know how it's going to do that
um but it's good to kind of try to
start to formulate different ideas
different frameworks of how we think
about that exactly at the small scale of
a collection of individuals a large
scale of a society exactly it's a meme i
think it's i think it's an example of a
good meme and i'm open i'd love to hear
feedback from people if they think it's
that you know they have a better idea or
it's not you know but it's the direction
of meme that we need to spread this idea
of like look for the win wins in life
you